I'm a veteran of the infantry and when I
took over a fire team for the first time
I made the mistake of drawing hard lines
in the sand this immediately alienated
members of that team that had been
together for some time I did not make
that mistake again
and I definitely learn from my
experience so clearly there's not a
question there yeah and and I forget
pulling this out from I get a lot of
emails and messages and all that but I
thought it was a good point to bring up
to say you know this idea of drawing
hard lines in the sand and what that
does to your leadership position it's
it's a it's a difficult it's usually not
a good thing to do if you draw a lot
hard lines in the sand and eventually
you realize that they're either
unrealistic or people can't maintain
them you have set yourself up for
failure what is that exactly so it's no
matter what we will not cut bla bla bla
yeah there's the leg no matter what we
will we will win every single Road marks
that we do as a fire team in this while
while we're here on this training thing
mmm okay well guess what that's a that's
hard there's other there's some other
fire teams that are also want to win and
and so you've drawn a hard line to send
that's not really a good example of a
good example to take no matter what
we're gonna muster every morning at 4:30
in the morning mm-hmm no matter what and
you know then the guys are out on patrol
until 2:38 in the morning and now the
next morning a good no matter what a
similar one well it's it's not good for
them it's unrealistic so you do a hard
line in the sand and now you got to back
it down so and all you have to do is
soften the statement a little bit hey
guys
to the best of our ability if we can
we're gonna get here every morning at
4:30 from muster there's a little
there's a little room to play there
right and that's that's fine so again I
I there's there's not a lot of there's
not a question here but one of the
reasons I think that that I that I
wanted
talk about it was because I think people
look at me yeah and even hear me on a
peripheral level and they think all I
bet Chuck will just lay down the hard
night it's my way or the highway right
yeah and and the the opposite is
actually true and the reason that I came
to that conclusion was because I worked
for leaders like that and I hated
working for leaders like that so I tried
to never be a leader like that hmm and
there's a dichotomy right there's a huge
dichotomy because this doesn't mean that
you're not driving and pushing this
doesn't mean that you're not saying hey
we're gonna be the best whatever we're
to be the best task unit here doesn't
mean you're not saying hey look we're
not gonna rest until we've done what
we're supposed to do doesn't mean that
mmm but man you got to find that balance
yeah